let's say that we have a line i'm
drawing it right over there
and our goal
is to construct
another line that is parallel to this
line that goes through this point
how would we do that
well the way that we can approach it is
by creating what will eventually be a
transversal between the two parallel
lines
so let me draw that so i'm just drawing
a line that goes through my point and
intersects my original line
doing that so it's going to look like
that
and then i'm really just going to use
the idea of corresponding angle
congruence for parallel lines
so what i can do is now take my compass
and think about this angle right over
here
so i'll draw it like that
and say all right if i have if i draw an
arc of the same radius over here
can i reconstruct that angle
and so where should the point be on this
on this left end well to do that i can
just
measure
the distance between these two points
using my compass so i'm adjusting it a
little bit to get the point the distance
between those two points and then i can
use that up
over here
to figure out and got a little bit shaky
i could figure out that point right over
there
and just like that i now have two
corresponding angles
defined by transversal and parallel
lines so what i could do is take my
straight edge and make it go
through those points that i just created
so let's see make sure i'm going through
them and it would look like that
and i have just constructed
two parallel lines and once again how do
i know that this line is parallel to
this line
because we have a transversal that
intersects both of them and these two
angles which are corresponding angles
are congruent so these two lines must be
parallel